pensiamo che lavorare su una pellicola
che appartiene a circa un centinaio di
anni fa almeno perché il cinema nasce
nel 1895 e poi abbiamo i primi esempi
già particolarmente importanti e
rilevanti di filmografia a partire dal
1910 andare quindi a lavorare su
pellicole che chiaramente partono da
quella che l'idea di una trasposizione
filmica di un elemento del vissuto
quotidiano e che poi diventano invece a
loro volta narratività e trattazione di
alcuni temi particolarmente rilevanti e
farlo con musiche che invece tengano
conto non soltanto di quella che la
grande tradizione musicale ma
soprattutto anche l'evoluzione delle
tecniche compositive che si è allineata
nel secolo scorso e si è evoluta nel
secolo scorso in una maniera
esponenziale naturalmente pone un
problema essenziale per noi compositori
che lavoriamo in queste in questo
settore come andare a lavorare su una
pellicola storica che ha in sé
rappresenta già di suo una coppia
originale perché di solito ce ne
pervengono una due copie di quello che
era il film originale e molto poco
spesso in realtà raramente possiamo dire
con una colonna sonora originale Ma come
facciamo a ricostruire quella quel
tessuto con l'immaginario quel
background quella atmosfera che in
realtà era di quegli anni ma
contemporaneamente andare a lavorare
come tipico per un compositore nel senso
dell'Innovazione nel senso della ricerca
di qualcosa di nuovo e di fortemente
identitario che possa non negare la
valenza di quella che l'originalità
della pellicola stessa e allora l'idea è
proprio questa cioè l'originale
contemporaneo della copia originale che
cosa deve diventare cosa deve essere
realmente
pensiamo che questo è un dilemma col
quale ci confrontiamo noi compositori
che lavoriamo proprio in questo settore
In maniera particolare perché si
potrebbe naturalmente immaginare un
stessa tipologia di lavoro completamente
divelto rispetto al passato rispetto
alla tradizione però abbiamo un problema
che si chiama funzionalità ovvero il
l'aspetto primo che si impara nel creare
una sonorizzazione per il cinema in
senso generale non soltanto nel cinema
non sonoro ovviamente
è la musica deve avere un'interazione
con l'immagine con la parte filmica ora
dobbiamo pensare un aspetto essenziale
oggi come oggi il non possiamo nemmeno
più parlare di binomio musica e cinema
perché si è creato un tale sincretismo
in questi due mondi tra loro
apparentemente inizialmente collocati su
due binari che potevano intersecarsi Ma
attualmente si è creato una tale osmosi
i così importante così rilevante da
poter parlare di una sorta di Opera
Totale siamo quello che abbiamo imparato
con la tragedia greca e poi con il
melodramma possiamo dire di dividerlo
oggi di un film che realmente funzioni e
questo Naturalmente Sia nel caso in cui
si tratti di un'opera filmica di 100
anni fa sia nel caso in cui invece si va
da trattare di un'opera filmica
contemporanea e allora Naturalmente il
nostro
diciamo il nostro lavoro con
positivamente Quale deve essere trovare
una modalità per riuscire a rimanere
nella funzionalità per rispettare quella
che è la copia originale ci consegna
come immagine filmica ma
contemporaneamente andare ad individuare
un linguaggio che diventi linguaggio
identitario che porti un nuovo originale
sulla nostra scena E da questo punto di
vista la tematica di oggi era
particolarmente interessante e rilevante
Questo è un problema che non ci poniamo
soltanto oggi perché voi dovete
immaginare che già i tempi e il primo
filmato il primo spezzone che io vi
proporrò sarà proprio di essere e il
regista per eccellenza con il quale ha
rappresentato una pietra miliare
all'interno dell'evoluzione della storia
del cinema benissimo famosissimo
sargheseinstein diceva proprio questo
nella richiesta per le musiche di
corazzata Potëmkin Chi di voi non
conosce corazzata Potëmkin Fantozzi Lo
ha reso conoscibile a tutto il a tutta
l'umanità Beh in realtà
ha realizzato questa pellicola di valore
incredibile da una serie di punti di
vista e nel momento in cui ha lavorato
sulla parte musicale ha espresso una
richiesta specifica
appunto formalizzato unica richiesta
categorica per la musica abbandonare
l'abituale stile melodico fondandosi
interamente su un ritmico battere di
percussioni e stabilire Inoltre nel
punto decisivo nella musica come nel
film un passaggio repentino ad una
qualità nuova nella struttura sonora
Sardegna lavora per la prima versione di
corazzata Potëmkin con un compositore
non particolarmente affermato non
particolarmente acclamato ma è
importante in quegli anni nell'ambito
della cinematografia che Edmond meiselle
vengono dati soltanto 15 giorni
all'incirca ed un maisel riesce a
scrivere l'intera partitura in 12 giorni
a consegnarla a sagesting in realtà è
una partitura estremamente funzionale
all'immagine e negli anni ci sono state
diverse sonorizzazioni che poi sono
state realizzate di questo film della
corazzata Potëmkin perché ho voluto
prendere come esempio proprio la
corazzata Potëmkin perché in realtà è un
film che io ho musicato per ben due
volte l'ho musicato per la prima volta
nel 2013 creando una partitura per
pianoforte e orchestra sinfonica che è
stata proprio realizzata in prima
esecuzione qui a Milano e invece un nel
2021 ha ricevuto la commissione dal
centro Tchaikovsky di San Pietroburgo
per poter creare E qui la Chicca
particolare per poter creare una nuova
partitura che però
dovesse essere un omaggio cecosky ora
nulla di più lontano da me dicejkowski
Nel senso che ha una linearità una
cantabilità o un lunghissimi fraseggi
musicali che ehm
sono fantastici ovviamente ma
nell'estetica che deriva da quella che è
stata la formazione nel secondo
Novecento ovviamente ben lontano però
c'era una commissione ad hoc e quindi
bisognava andare a lavorare su due
originali bisognava andare a lavorare
sull'originale della copia a noi
pervenuta con le musiche di Edmond
perché c'era un'aspettativa del
risultato e c'era Naturalmente una
consapevolezza di quello che poteva
essere realizzato e dall'altra parte
bisognava andare ad agire su un una
modalità precisa che era quella della
commissione ricevuta quindi una
richiesta di riferimento ad un
compositore importante e di repertorio
come Tchaikovsky Naturalmente il La
scelta è stata quella di studiare
profondamente Tchaikovsky ed individuare
una modalità per poter
corrispondentemente
avere a disposizione una partitura che
avesse quantomeno un ricordo una
determina ripristino dell'orchestrazione
e della Valenza
estremamente
spessa del di quello che poteva essere
la musica in quegli anni con un
linguaggio però che potesse tener
considerazione tutto quello che è
avvenuto nel frattempo nel Novecento E
allora io vi proporrei come prima come
primo ascolto e visione proprio questo
il finale della corazzata Potëmkin Voi
sapete che una pellicola importantissima
perché non soltanto affronto una
tematica sociale
rilevante Ovvero quella della
diseguaglianza ma affronta anche la
tematica in questo momento storico per
noi altrettanto rilevante che il
disvalore della guerra Permettetemi di
dirlo e non a caso quello che avviene
all'interno Nel quarto capitolo del film
che la scalinata di Odessa e un
esemplificazione massima di quello che
la guerra produce ovvero l'omicidio più
efferato viene compiuto sebbene
involontariamente proprio da una
nobildonna che
nell'essere a sua volta colpita
inavvertitamente spinge la famosa
carrozzina sulla sulla scalinata
uccidendo a sua volta suo figlio e in
realtà è quello che avviene nella guerra
senza distinzione di categorie sociali
senza distensione di
posizioni o di legami umani la morte e
ovunque
Eden è stato in grado di
avvertire tutto questo e di proporlo
nella maniera incredibile che la nostra
storia può ricordare benissimo questo è
la parte finale in cui in realtà c'è il
riscatto il riscatto di colori quali si
davano per persi Quindi c'è un momento
di grandissima tensione Sono all'incirca
un paio di minuti ma e il momento di
grande tensione precedente l'attacco che
poi in realtà non avverrà per cui i
marinai presenti sulla corazzata
Potëmkin si salveranno a voi ascolto e
visione
[Musica]
Ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]
benissimo il in questo caso è una
realizzazione live quella che avete
ascoltato fatta dall'Orchestra di stato
del governatorato nato di San
Pietroburgo e che in sincrono con
l'immagine naturalmente proprio per
riuscire a garantire quella che era la
fruizione realmente di una pellicola che
manteneva la sua storicità e che però
doveva essere accompagnata da una nuova
partitura che portasse insieme la
tradizione e l'innovazione il
la tipologia diciamo di approccio che si
può avere in casi in cui invece abbiamo
un contesto storico Popolare nella parte
filmica e ancora più un dilemma Nel
senso che io vi presenterò oggi Due
tipologie di approccio molto diverse tra
loro una che e quella in cui abbiamo un
sotteso un immaginario sotteso che in
realtà è quello del di una tradizione
storico culturale ovvero di un
patrimonio a cui noi potremmo
fondamentalmente attingere in questo
caso Come realizzare qualcosa che sia
funzionale al all'originale naturalmente
creando una copia che però abbia una sua
identità comunque anch'essa innovativa e
anche essa a sua volta originale Questo
è l'esempio che io
realizzo all'interno del Golem gargolem
come venne al mondo è un film
estremamente importante del periodo
espressionista parliamo del 1920 ed è ad
opera di carlsea e di Paul Wegener
wiegener addirittura presente
all'interno proprio del film nella festa
attoriale ed è la storia sostanzialmente
del della comunità ebraica e del della
persecuzione con una serie di ippodromo
nel XVI secolo nella
nel quartiere di Praga principale il
Robbie love che in quel momento era
presente sul territorio crea un mostro
di scintilla per poter difendere il
proprio popolo e qui si pone il problema
che un problema storico ma che in realtà
è un problema etico che ancora noi oggi
affrontiamo nel nostro quotidiano quanto
ascoltavamo anche nel primo intervento
l'idea dell'intelligenza artificiale
quanto possiamo investire sulla
creazione di qualcosa di lontano da noi
e che poi possa non allontanarsi
completamente da noi cioè di cui
possiamo continuare a gestire è un
problema che in questo film viene già
affrontato siamo nel 1920 e viene
affrontato con una lungimiranza
incredibile cioè una maniera per
cessare la vita di der Golem E qual è
togliere dalla dal corpo del Golem una
stella che ovviamente la stella della
comunità ebraica in cui all'interno è
contenuto un piccolissimo biglietto con
su scritto emet che verità e il Non a
caso la cessazione del dell'essere
creato ad hoc
trova una l'interruzione naturale nel
momento in cui viene estirpata la parola
verità della sua stessa esistenza in
questo caso la scelta doveva essere
quella di rispettare Naturalmente una
l'originale che contenuto già nel
tessuto narrativo nel plot del film e
riuscire a creare qualcosa che comunque
parlasse in maniera nuova allora un
elaborazione di quello che il materiale
connotativo della comunità ebraica lo
studio degli intervallistica lo studio
di tutto ciò che può generare il le
sensazioni che sono collegate
all'immaginario ebraico e la creazione
di una nuova partitura del Golem
[Musica]
bene con questo naturalmente pensiamo a
tutte queste tutto quello che può essere
offerto dalla copia e può essere
realizzato in originale Grazie davvero
[Applauso]